Famously start with e
raise to Pi with an i
then we're taught by a lot
that you've got
minus 1
Can we glean what it means?
For such words are absurd
How to treat the repeat of a feat
Pi I times
This is bound to confound
'til your mind redefines
these amounts one can't count
which surmount our friend e.
Numbers act as abstract
functions which slide the rich
2d space in its space with a grace
when they sum.
Multiplied, they don't slide,
acting a second way
They rotate, and dilate, but keep straight
that same plane.
Now that we write as e
to the x won't perplex
when you know it's for show
that 'x' goes up and right.
It does not, as you thought,
repeat e product e.
It functions with gumption on functions
we've now seen.
It turns slides side to side
into growths and shrinks both.
Up and downs come around
as turns round which is key!
This is why Pi times i,
which slides north is brought forth
and returned, we have learned,
as a turn halfway round.
Minus one, matched by none.
Turns this way hence we're done.